begin tonight with this Fox News Alert
the 45th president of the United States
the leading 2024 candidate Donald J
Trump has now been indicted by Joe
Biden's Department of Justice now for
the very first time in American history
a sitting president's doj has indicted
his top political rival ahead of a
presidential campaign now here is Donald
Trump just a few moments ago take a look
very sadly We're a nation of decline
and yet they go after a popular
president a president that got more
votes than any sitting president in the
history of our country by far
and did much better the second time in
the election than the first
and they go after him on a Box's hoax
just like the russia-russia Russia hoax
and all of the others this has been
going on for seven years they can't stop
because it's election interference at
the highest level there's never been
anything like what's happened I'm an
innocent man I'm an innocent person they
had the Mueller hoax the Mueller report
and that came out no collusion after two
and a half years that was set up by
Hillary Clinton and Democrats but this
is what they do this is what they do so
well if they would devote their energies
to honesty and integrity would be a lot
better for our country they could do a
lot better they could do a lot of great
things
now on Truth social he also wrote quote
the corrupt Biden Administration has
informed my attorneys that I have been
indicted seemingly over the boxes hoax
even though Joe Biden has
1850 boxes at the University of Delaware
additional boxes in Chinatown and DC
more boxes at the UPenn Biden Center and
documents strewn all over his garage
floor where he Parks his Corvette and
which is secured by only a garage door
that is paper thin and open uh much of
the time he continues quote I have been
summoned to appear at the federal
courthouse in Miami on Tuesday at 3 P.M
I never thought it possible that such a
thing could happen to a former president
of the United States who received far
more many votes than any sitting
president in the history of our country
and is currently leading by far all
candidates both Democrat and Republican
in the polls of the 22 24 presidential
election I am an innocent man this is
indeed a dark day for the United States
of America we are a country in serious
and Rapid decline but together we'll
make America great again now president
Trump has been indicted on seven counts
that much we know all related to his
handling of those classified documents
and quote what we call Process crimes
obstruction of justice meanwhile
absolutely no charges against Joe Biden
even top secret classified documents
from as far back as his time as Senator
that turned up in multiple locations
utilized by Joe including an unsecured
office building in D.C and Biden's very
own garage apparently mishandling top
secret documents is okay if you're a
Biden or a Clinton or I guess a Democrat
for that matter Hillary mishandled
America's secrets on an unsecured
private server that we were told was
likely hacked by foreign countries and
then she attempted to come cover her
tracks by deleting 33 000 emails wiping
hard drives on computers off with
something called bleach bit kind of acid
washing the hard drives and then of
course destroying phones and and
blackberries with hammers and removing
SIM cards but According to Jim Comey no
reasonable prosecutor would bring
charges against Hillary Clinton now of
course it is a very different story when
it comes to Trump he is now facing
multiple charges because of a few
documents from his own presidency stored
in a secure room at Mar-A-Lago with a
padlock on the door by the way I'll say
about this room a room that the FBI
previously had access to unfettered
access and as a matter of fact had the
opportunity to remove items if they
wanted to uh the only thing they
requested was to put a second lock on
the door a padlock that was complied
with by the Trump people down at
Mar-A-Lago meanwhile Joe Biden can store
similar documents in a box and a wide
open garage nobody seems to care and
let's not forget about the 2016
allegations of bribery against Joe Biden
from the quote trusted confidential
human source that even the Obama bite
Administration ended up paying on
occasion according to foxnews.com The
Source detail conversations with a
barisma executive to the FBI this
executive reportedly referred to Hunter
as dumb but quote had to pay the bidens
because Ukrainian prosecutor Victor
shulkin was investigating barisma and it
would be difficult
it would be how difficult it would be to
enter the U.S market in the midst of
that investigation now that was of
course the very same Ukrainian
prosecutor that Biden ultimately
demanded be fired by leveraging one
billion taxpayer dollars The Source
claimed that a five million dollar
payment was directed to Joe Biden and
another five million dollar payment to
Hunter Biden but as Fox News news.com
reports these payments they weren't
direct payments instead they were made
quote through so many different bank
accounts that investigators would not be
able to unravel this for at least 10
years now again these are allegations
made by a confidential human Source
that's the 1023 form we've been talking
about who has worked with the FBI for
years trusted by the FBI the FBI paid
this individual two hundred thousand
dollars for some of his Intel Intel and
yet as far as we know the doj is not
pursuing a case against Joe Biden Hunter
Biden the big guy or anybody instead
it's is Republican Challenger Donald
Trump who's now facing the Wrath of the
doj surrounding the storage of documents
from his very own presidency yes it is a
dark day in America we've said it often
there's no equal justice there's no
equal application of our laws there's
one set of rules for Democrats another
set of rules for Donald Trump and
conservatives and anybody especially in
his orbit our system of justice has now
been weaponized beyond belief and this
country is in serious trouble hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else